so I wanted to ask you like starting
ballet stardew valley you talked about
stardew valley was a big hit on my
podcast it was about this little over
300,000 views now and the people on the
subreddit were going crazy they were
dying I moved on I did star do I
I got ten million dollars or fifty
million dollars per character which
means that I've had all the wizard stuff
like the towers and the golden the
golden clock right what takes all the
debris it just gets to the point where
it's like I have so much money I don't
even know I'm you can go to this casino
and buy this statue from the Sun I which
costs a million dollars but I had 15 of
those I'd cost
I spent like 15 million dollars right oh
yeah and then your it my kids are
running around and everything and then
you just get to the point where you go
on 47 and then I started playing this
other game called Far Cry 5 intense you
like that I never play loved it these
are the best one out of all is there
every game you put when you don't play
after like 5 or 10 or 15 hours and
you're like oh no I'm 47
like what games don't me I'm a gamer too
and part of the joy that's a loss for me
is that I'm like I always have this
feeling of like I should be doing
something else even though I hate that I
want to be in the moment and just enjoy
the video games well you know I when
Jordan Peele got that Oscar right I
thought to myself right this is a drip
because he is he the one that introduced
me to video games right yeah he is the
one that introduced me to I remember
going to the game stopped to get moral
wind right he's the one that goes you
got to get that game because he's like
well it into RPGs at all Bethesda so and
then he stopped playing stop smoking pot
and in that now he's now a he's a
Academy Award winner right I'm I mean
even if I didn't play video games I
would never never be able to do what he
does right but my point is is that I
could have achieved more but the
pleasure that I get from it I'm now way
is you're I'm not sure outweighs an
Oscar throw that off
no I before when I was working a desk
job at a job at 9:00 to 5:00 yeah I'll
come home and play video games and it
was like that was my joy you know and I
feel like that joy is gone I don't know
if it's because I'm depressed I don't
know if it's because I maybe it's
because I'm depressed I don't know but I
feel like there's always a there's
always like a sensor me that's like you
should be doing so most yeah and you
know why that's a normal healthy thing I
just don't have that I refuse to get in
you know there's a balance I'm gonna
play it at night I'll give a [ __ ] what
are you gonna plate it I started over
with I'd finished far cry five and I
started with awards it's a grinding game
to let you play got a warrant
I hate slashers you know here's the new
plan section oh no you know the
PlayStation and also don't I don't like
slash them hack them stop you know me I
like um very RPG though - I know it is
okay that's great
but I like I like part right because um
I should play park I like sneaking yeah
I like taking my binoculars and scoping
out a compound open-world I'm finding
out where everyone is right
I like figure out how to get into the
compound without anyone seeing me right
I like throwing rocks you could throw
bombs yourself boy yeah would you throw
a rock the characters go whoo I guess
the coast is clear
yeah all right and so they'll go toward
the rock oh you guys satisfaction what's
your favorite game of all time he's
trying to end the show yeah my favorite
game of all I was wondering if you were
fallout guy which one though I really
enjoyed the last one for ya I never
played for it cuz everybody says oh it's
just like three and I love fallout
fallout and I skip the whole [ __ ]
thing because everybody dissuaded me no
fallout 4 is another masterpiece because
it got new vegas he's way better because
okay I'm gonna play them I'll tell you
why New Vegas is better than New Vegas
because New Vegas there was no house
right oh you like the house aspect I
like building a house from
ground
[Music]